[Music]
the bigger the better is a phrase you
will not hear from a researcher at the
scp foundation larger anomalies can be a
nightmare to secure contain and protect
and if you're new around here that's
kind of the foundation's whole thing but
how broad is the spectrum of anomalous
size what deadly things come in small
packages and what anomalous threats
could lay waste to the world in a
footstep these are exactly the ideas
we're exploring today with our big
question what's the biggest scp alright
let's now set a few ground rules before
we jump headlong into the action no
entirely anomalous planets or alternate
dimensions this may seem like we're
excluding anomalies like scp-2935-o
death the alternate dimension where
death itself has overtaken everything or
scp-4774 a theoretical anomalous gas
giant that's two to four times the
diameter of earth but it's a little
unfair to some of the other hardworking
big scps by skewing the results with
whole universes or literal celestial
bodies we're also excluding
shapeshifters and reality warpers who
could theoretically be any size they
like if you have a problem with that we
kindly invite you to take it up with the
director of our complaint department
scp-106 he's horrifying i highly suggest
you don't do that now then for those who
haven't now been dragged into a pocket
dimension to endure centuries of
unspeakable horrors we'll start with the
pip squeaks and work our way up to the
oh lord he coming stage of anomalous
size our hard-working researchers have
concluded through rigorous study that
one of the most itty-bitty scps is
undeniably
scp-008 a terrifying prion with
incredible infectivity rates that
effectively turns its victims into
walking dead style zombies with the only
known cure being scp-500
prions are beyond tiny at only around
253 amino acids in length they can only
be seen via an electron microscope and
they make viruses look beefy by
comparison that doesn't mean if you get
infected it won't seriously mess up your
day to put it extremely extremely
lightly so what's next we've got
something like scp-165
also known as the creeping hungry sands
of tule we know what you're thinking
seriously we have the technology for
that and we also know you're thinking
hey that's a lot of sand what do you
mean that's only one step above a virus
that's because this erastus sand is
actually made up of tiny parasitic mites
only about 750 micrometers in length but
once again don't let their tiny size
fool you they can knock you out and eat
you to the bone in minutes but hey at
least they'll leave bones unlike the
nightmarish flying ant creatures coming
out of scp-743 the chocolate fountain
this fountain which is perfect for
weddings corporate retreats and birthday
parties for your worst enemies has the
most delicious chocolate you've ever
tasted problem is if you ever ingest it
millions of these nightmarish ant-like
monsters will swarm in soon after and
devour you and everyone you love
horrifying the body horror earwigs of
scp-439 are in this same weight class as
monsters with the size and general
appearance of pre-existing non-anomalous
insects except you don't need to have a
phobia of them for these little suckers
to make your worst nightmares come true
but you know who loves bugs birds birds
such as the common corn creek like scp
scp-2337 also known as dr spanko though
dr spanko prefers bugs of the gummy
variety he can also literally talk you
to death with a voice so loud and
booming it'll destroy your very selves
if you're exposed to it for too long it
also sounds like me but his body isn't
too long at a manageable 27 to 30
centimeters he's a similar size to other
fun little critters like scp-131 the
ipods and less fun little critters like
scp-689 the haunter in the dark the
weight and height class above this is
one that a huge number of scps fall into
roughly human or a little above or below
the old man kane abel god the sculpture
the plague doctor the tickle monster the
swamp woman and bigfoot and just above
that we've got a number of the scp heavy
hitters
scp-096 scp-682
ferdinand the cannibal cthulhu scp-5031
major alexei bellatrov and the list goes
on but honestly these are all still
small potatoes we're playing with the
big boys now literally what follows are
some of the biggest scps our in-house
foundation scientists could find from
dear god that's huge to so big that your
mind might boil in your head like an egg
just trying to comprehend it what are we
waiting for let's make like gaston and
get large first we head to
scp-1730 the nightmarish
interdimensional site 13. no we're not
going to cop out and hit you with a
building we're talking more about one of
its scariest occupants the giant
bloodthirsty monster known as leech boy
once an anomalous child named elijah the
abomination is now a 200 meter long
brood mother with a hive mind
controlling swarms of deadly anomalous
leeches
even in a building literally full of
terrifying anomalous monsters leechboy
was able to dominate with his size and
power until of course he ran into the
next entry on the list
scp-001 the gate guardian this cosmic
celestial flame warrior stands at 700
cubits tall which equates to an
incredible 320 meters over half the
height of the empire state building if
his hotter than the sun greatsword
doesn't get you he can always just step
on you and believe us there will be
literally nothing left after he does so
it makes sense after all you really
don't want a pipsqueak guarding the
gates to paradise but what's a servant
to the gods to an actual bonafide god
let's take a look at another scp-001
that proves to be terrifyingly big
straight from the oroboro cycle
scp-001 apotheosis also known as the
broken god we don't have exact numbers
on the size of this giant metal
monstrosity largely due to the fact that
it kept getting bigger and bigger as it
integrated more matter into its already
massive body the sheer scale of this
utter behemoth is best expressed in what
it was capable of doing and what it took
to eventually put it down the monster
caused considerable chaos across all of
western mexico leading to the largest
deployment of amnestics after the fact
in scp foundation history in order to
eventually beat the thing they needed to
get a hand from a certain other anomaly
but we'll discuss that one a little more
later in the video if you thought a
giant metal monstrosity nicknamed the
world eater by some is scary then you'll
be quaking in your boots at the mere
thought of our next scp scp-4006
massachusetts this incredibly anomalous
state is afflicted by a probabilistic
anomaly known as the veil which is meant
to maintain a sense of normalcy and
tricks people into thinking that the
state of massachusetts has ever been
occupied by humans in fact the location
has been entirely devoid of human
civilization since the dawn of time
we're all just victims of the anomaly
that makes us think otherwise our next
contestant isn't wider than the
anomalous state of massachusetts but
he's a hell of a lot taller and way way
more dangerous it is the apocalyptic
monster trapped beyond scp-2317
the devourer of worlds this monster is
likely destined to perform an xk-class
end-of-the-world scenario against us as
it already has in other worlds it's an
utterly monstrous 200 kilometers tall
think 400 empire state buildings stacked
on top of each other and then some it's
a being that likely no weapon humanity
or even the scp foundation has devised
will be able to even slow down if ever
he breaks free we can only hope that
death will come quickly but his size has
nothing compared to some of the beasts
that lurk below take the legendary
scp-3000 the godlike underwater being
known to some as anatashia this huge
eel-like monster is the leading provider
of amnestics for the scp foundation as
long as they can provide it with ample
sacrifices in return it's a being so big
and so deep underwater that it's
difficult to truly know the creature's
length some estimates have put it around
or even above an incredible 900
kilometers that's over twice the length
of a fellow anomaly the state of
massachusetts it is a perfect example of
some of the terrifying things waiting
underneath so what if we told you that
there was something even longer even
larger than the terrifying anatashia
lurking below us as you watch this very
video and furthermore what if we told
you that it was super adorable too meet
scp-2950
also known as the infinite corgi this
male pembroke welsh corgi measures over
30 000 kilometers in length that's a
hell of a lot of good boy where could we
possibly keep it all well his head and
front legs protrude adorably from the
ground in portland oregon and his 30 000
kilometers of corgi body places rear end
in a rural area of japan's karawa
district his body weaves under the
americas europe and much of asia putting
the length of anatashia to shame there's
a lot more to
scp-2952 than we can really get into
here but if you want a full video on the
world's longest good boy sound off about
it in the comments and now we're down to
the big three the ones that could drive
you mad even trying to comprehend their
scale try to take it all in if they can
even fit into your field of vision while
this next anomaly isn't as long as the
infinite corki its shear bulk is
terrifying on a whole different level
it's scp-169
also known as the leviathan thankfully
this incredible beast is lying dormant
underneath an archipelago but like the
world's various scary super volcanoes
the risk of the leviathan someday rising
and causing chaos across the globe with
its mere movements is never out of the
question just in terms of sheer raw
largeness
scp-169 is probably the biggest anomaly
currently living on earth but that
doesn't mean we're done just yet for our
next two shining examples of
megalophobia-inducing monstrosity we
need to head a little further out into
the cosmos first to the creature sucking
the life out of the giant star that
gives us all life
scp-1682 also known as the solar
parasite this monster is described by
personnel on the caves as a kind of
cosmic tapeworm that siphons energy out
of stars like our sun it's over 28 000
kilometers long and there's a good
chance that it means us great harm just
goes to show there are no good tapeworms
whether they're wreaking havoc on your
intestines or your entire solar system
and now the big daddy to end all big
daddies the biggest scp that isn't a
planet dimension or portion of space scp
scp-2399
an unimaginably huge weapon of mass
destruction known as a malfunctioning
destroyer this alien superweapon sent to
completely destroy the earth instead
ended up getting stranded on jupiter and
causing a mark on the surface known as
the great red eye which by the way is
bigger than the entirety of planet earth
it's currently being repaired and if it
ever completes its goal it will likely
continue its mission and wipe us all out
to give you an idea of just how much
more powerful this mechanized alien
nightmare is compared to pretty much
everything else on this list
scp-2399 was instrumental in defeating
and eventually destroying
scp-001 apotheosis the broken god seeing
as it's currently 713 million miles away
it's difficult to tell exactly how big
scp-2399
is but one thing is for sure if ever you
get close enough to find out you're as
good as dad so there you have it the
biggest scps out there which was your
favorite let us know down in the
comments oh and if you're new here be
sure to subscribe it can make a big
difference that was a terrible joke i'm
very sorry now go check out scp-2935
oh death and more epic scp stories you
can't miss and scp-002 the living room
and most terrifying scp rooms for more
unforgettable anomalous compilations
from scp explained